podcast host and writer solomon butchie
posted a tribute to his fiancee that
caused the backlash on social media it
reads not the most beautiful woman
neither are you the most intelligent
woman but i've chosen
never to find perfection in anyone else
he later clarified it by saying it may
not sound like a compliment but it's a
realistic base for love
and and i get it you know because people
say we'll say to you you know that's not
the most beautiful one you could be with
some and he's saying she's not the most
beautiful not the brightest either but i
love her you know what it reminds me of
i didn't think it was a bad thing i hate
him it reminds me of that rogers and hot
song my fa my funny valentine yeah the
most insulting song i've ever heard
your looks are laughable and
photographable yeah is your figure less
than greek is your mouth a little weak
when you open it to speak are you smart
you know what sought off as the brits
say yeah you know what that's an
insulting song it's a nasty little song
i hate that stuff yeah
and i hate i hate this guy the song that
we like though is tell me lies tell me
sweetly
well
at least
they're honest about it yeah they they
are i will give them that they are 100
honest about that [ __ ] they want people
to lie to them
that's honest
and that's okay
do i look fat in this dress no you don't
you look fat
hey man that time it was a1 i was mad
bro
the [ __ ] don't even exist and i could
picture it in my head i said i hurt for
her who's this imaginary woman you just
shot that
and it's and you know what and you would
go ahead it's okay
but but then again you know i understand
the two sides of it and i understand
like you don't have why don't you have
to go out there and [ __ ] say that
[ __ ]
move on [ __ ] don't like who you
would move you don't have to broadcast
it while she ain't doing it
but everybody deals with these [ __ ] the
way they deal with that's how i would
deal with it about [ __ ] okay it's like
you know i wouldn't be going out of
social media knowing my girl is not the
smartest be like yeah that's my dum-dum
over there
i wouldn't do that [ __ ] cause that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is [ __ ] weird but
that again whether it's the truth or not
you know not all truth you know you
can't say
not all truth is worthy i mean said like
you know i i worry about
this guy i hate him but i worry about
this guy for this woman because as they
you know if they get married i would
marry him after saying all that but like
as she gets older what is he going to do
oh babe you look a little fat today oh
babe that was really stupid that you
said that no no no that's your feelings
talking he didn't he didn't do that he
didn't go to that extent he didn't go
there but i understand and he told you
like you're really just listening and
you're just hearing what you want to
hear right because he said hey i like
that and i choose
not to see perfection in other people so
you're not you decide not to listen to
that but you you decide to run your
whole little scenario in your head what
is he gonna do when he's gonna be over
hey
he never said none of that
you tripping that's too much sauce
okay i don't like that your partner
should lie to you if they no they
shouldn't lie to you oh my god beautiful
though
and by the way i would know i she's very
beautiful in the picture we put up she
looks better than he does she's better
looking at him i will say this my
husband this is how you know this whole
positivity
all this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
the moment these hoes hear you say
something they didn't like they say you
ugly ass troglodyte goblin looking lord
of the rings [ __ ] extra you
piece of [ __ ] belonging in your mama's
basement looking extra oh listen i just
appreciate all bodies are beautiful all
women are beautiful uh i don't think my
wife's hot you ugly pieces
whoa the transition is fascinating what
happened to being positive
i
that's why i would piece my girl
out of all these women
i'm mad at you will be my girl i will
say this my husband justin um he does
tell me sweet little lies and i prefer
that yes do i know that he thinks
duolipus hotter than me yes but i still
want him to tell me i'm the most
beautiful woman in the world yeah like
and by the way the knock on her
intelligence might be the worst part
like justin would be sleeping outside if
you said you know my wife's not the most
intelligent can i break with you i'm not
saying here purely because i think he
his attempt might have failed a little
bit because i don't think you need to
put that out in writing like we all we
know imagine matching you sarah you're
not that cute well i can say it i don't
like when he's that's not what
about
call
yes man you heard it from the [ __ ]
horse's mouth
i can say it but he
i was gonna make this point but they
made it for me thank you man
uh what's your name
sarah okay sour horse mouth let me say
this okay maybe y'all grew up in a
different time i grew up
pretty my entire life hearing
wives on television talk about how ugly
they husbands are or how like pudgy and
whatever he is or how incompetent he is
in fact that's a meme in most
advertisement the incompetent it's not a
meme it's a stereotype
okay people talk about it online oh my
husband can't do anything pretty much
useless uh but you know i love him
anyways
this is normal
a dude gets out here and says something
that's very realistic i'll bet maybe he
shouldn't have been on social media
whatever it is but if she's cool with it
and he's cool with it what's the issue i
think we
we hold women to this idea that they
have to be the most beautiful woman how
do you juxtapose two things
one
we put women up to unrealistic beauty
standards every single day
at the same time honey you're the most
beautiful woman in the world
that's unrealistic you're you're
assuming that's unrealistic right there
right there you said it
you just [ __ ] said it so your
daughter's gonna see that and she's
gonna learn that i have to be the most
beautiful
it's like you're upholding a lot of
these unrealistic standards i understand
that within the confines of your
relationship you want to be desired your
partner guess what and this is the truth
for most people and women will say this
about their partners and men will say
this about their partners
most people know the partner's not the
hottest it's probably not even the
hottest that the person even slept with
or been with
but they still choose to be with someone
rather than seeing that as something
disgusting to admit i think it's
something very beautiful about the fact
that you're willing to compromise in
certain areas or you're saying you know
what i want to build or something
something big i'm not out here trying to
look for optimum everything the most
amount of money the most amount of
beauty those i'm like yo i'm gonna have
faith in you to build the rest of my
life going forward and rather seeing it
that way everyone's just like this
unromantic let me tell y'all romance is
[ __ ] i don't think men are
constantly what is
romance i don't think it is i don't
think it's what it is the romance that
is expected in the media is sure that's
what the normal the romance can happen
anytime
the romans that you're talking about
that is just unrealistic and just wack
is like
valentine's day yeah expected to have 12
okay a bouquet of 12 roses when the
roses are [ __ ] expansive as [ __ ]
whereas 23rd of july
what's on our 23rd nothing
out of the blue that's good when i was
in a time where
i initially didn't have the money or the
means or whatever what not or whatever
to do whatever it's whenever i could
and listen i was at the grocery store i
thought about you and i thought you
would like to have a bouquet of roses or
bouquet of flowers it doesn't have to be
roses whatever but i was thinking about
you a gesture a gesture that's the
romance but it's not the dictated
romance whereas
you need to have a diamond ring with how
many carrots and your wife has to be the
most beautiful it's like how can you do
how can you complain about beauty
standards
and at the same time want to be the
beauty the unrealistic beauty standard
that sounds dumb to me
but it was really just on the the the
romance thing i'm like no no romance is
still a thing like if i decide to cook
for you
you didn't take me to the restaurant no
[ __ ] i cooked i cooked a meal that i
know that you like that i know i can't
cook i put all my effort in that [ __ ]
and we're gonna eat it together that's
for facts bro that's romance but yeah of
course the romance that they expect
there that the most expensive restaurant
the most expensive bouquet the most
exciting diamond rings and [ __ ] like
that that [ __ ] could be swarovski
with crystals and not diamonds
i thought about you brother
i can say this is from a dating
perspective i've had women come back and
apologize to me afterwards after like we
dated for some time because they were
like yo you know what i realized that
was like what it's like
i didn't realize that you loved me in
your own way sometimes that's what you
mean it's like you were doing stuff but
i didn't internalize it because i had a
vision of what i imagined love was
supposed to yes
and so
for me i knew that within the confines
of that dynamic it's like i can only go
so much outside of myself before i start
to lose myself in the sauce and it
starts to feel so unnatural i feel
uncomfortable throughout the whole thing
you know what i mean it's it's like this
is who i am if you want to date me like
i'm giving that and i'll try to make
some adjustments here and there but it's
like when you have an idea of what your
perfect mate is supposed to be like it's
very stifling um
how to explain this i've had a few
dating experiences where i felt like
i really liked the person across from me
but i feel like when they looked at me
sometimes they had a cardboard cut out
of what they thought their partner was
supposed to look like absolutely and
they're like
i know you're six foot tall
but this cardboard cut out six foot
three and i'm just trying to see if i
can cram you can you make this post and
it's just like
there's no space for me to show you my
strengths because you're so busy trying
to fit me through this and mind you he's
just talking about stuff that is
physical but you can transpose that into
things that are you know not so physical
so whenever metaphors and that's why the
thing that like the different the five
languages of love is important in that
sense where in your whole life if you've
been raised up to always think i love
you i love you i love you i love you i
love you i love you i love you i love
you i love you i love you i love you i
love you i love you to show your love
and that's the only thing and the only
way that you understand
love is by someone saying it
someone proving their love to you in
another way might be totally casper to
friendly ghosts and i've had people come
up to me like yo this guy doesn't never
say that he loves me i don't even know
he look i'm not like
he brought you this he brought you that
he cooked dinner for you he thought
about you he brought you a coffee the
way that you like all of those shits
is what it is but you try to fit it like
you try to say in that cardboard i love
you i love you want me to make you say i
love i don't say i love you because it
doesn't have any value to me
it doesn't
for you for me
i feel like within this conversation
that's one of the key points
this is their relationship if she good
with it and he good with it what's it to
you oh yeah you like being told you're
the most beautiful woman in the world
and getting all these comic points i can
assure you i know women out there who
hate hearing that kind of [ __ ] because
they think it's disingenuous and they
start to question all your behavior this
guy just trying to put matt game on me
is he just trying to say this they
resent that and these women will be in
the comments right now saying i don't
like it when dudes put on too many
compliments or when it sounds
inauthentic
i'd rather they just give me a realistic
compliment that i can really buy into
i'm good with that but don't do too much
some people don't me personally i really
don't care for the compliments
at all like if you didn't get i wouldn't
even give a [ __ ]
so people are different
and now here's someone expressing their
love in a way that's authentic to them
and their partner everyone's like you
piece of [ __ ] she better
uh stupid is it your relationship
i would never you're not the one getting
married to him
yeah but if it was
you're not even the job is not open boom
we didn't take your application honey i
don't mind if people say it's not my
thing that's cool yeah okay not your
thing yeah i understand what you're
saying she better divorce him
how does she there's no way she what
kind of man would do
the man that she wants to be with
the same way people got different ways
of expressing their love in a
relationship honey boo boo if my girl
still saw me like that we you won't be
single very soon but that's for them
don't
i think that's revolting i would much
rather be like you kind of mediocre but
i still like hey that's more my vibe
i can't do that
everybody operates different that's all
i'm trying i'm not even saying this way
is right i'm not saying that i'm saying
let them move how they move unless they
discontent with it why is everybody
making such a big fuss about maybe i
miss that
but it is what it is
[Music]
that's good oh though if you don't get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] but
if that's how you do that's how you do
but i'm gonna cringe when i'm gonna hear
it but it's not for me it's just not for
me but if it floats your boat and your
[ __ ] are happy with this ugh
that guy got google [ __ ] then
all the way out of the [ __ ] over there
we're not gonna google in this [ __ ]
we're not we're not doing this i don't
got i don't god god google with kids
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do
google with an idols